[Música]
nuestra segunda invitada del día es una
persona que abre camino tenemos la
suerte de contar con la abogada Tamara
Adrián la primera persona trans en
emprender una carrera hacia la
presidencia ella concurre a las
primarias de este próximo octubre de la
plataforma unitaria la coalición de la
oposición venezolana para elegir
candidato de Cara a las presidenciales
de 2024 pero Tamara ya hizo historia
antes cuando en 2015 se convirtió en la
primera mujer trans en ser diputada en
América Latina Tamara bienvenida a
France 24 quería preguntarle Con qué
reacciones se encontró al hacer el
anuncio
bueno mire Muchas gracias por esta
oportunidad de Rodrigo y Y sí como
siempre lo digo hay reacciones diversas
la gran mayoría son de apoyo de respeto
y algunas que provienen de sectores muy
conservadores diría yo radical
conservador o fundamentalista que
como Frente a cualquier lucha contra
hegemónica Y eso pasó por ejemplo en
Colombia con Francia Márquez por el tema
raza ha atado por el tema religión por
orientación sexual por identidad de
género ahora siempre ocurre que estos
fundamentalistas tratan de mantener el
estatus quo y evitar que se rompa el
techo de cristal pero les doy una mala
noticia ya el techo está roto y lo más
que pueden hacer es tratar de pegarlo
con algún tipo de pegamento
Bueno usted ha sido diputada por el
partido del opositor Leopoldo López
voluntad popular Qué diferencias ve
usted entre las políticas de la
oposición y de la oficialismo frente al
respeto de los Derechos trans
no yo yo estoy postulada acá No por
voluntad popular donde pertenecía donde
estuve haciendo vida hay política
durante muchos años sino por Unidos por
la dignidad un Movimiento Político de
movimientos que hace de el tema
justamente de la dignidad humana y la
reivindicación de la dignidad como
elemento esencial del desarrollo humano
toda su filosofía y por ese movimiento
del que estoy estoy en este momento
postulada pero lo que queremos es el
desarrollo el tránsito hacia la
democracia en Venezuela el desarrollo
económico de Venezuela para que haya
futuro y la gente no se siga yendo pero
para eso necesitamos
reinstitucionalizar a Venezuela es decir
Estado de derecho justicia
y todo lo que tiene que ver con
impuestos lo que tiene que ver también
fundamentalmente con el tema de
administración de recursos tenemos nueve
años sin un presupuesto y sin rendición
de cuentas a los servicios públicos y
sobre todo la inclusión social Bueno ya
que habla usted del futuro de Venezuela
quería preguntarle cuál es su plan para
combatir la pobreza y El Éxodo del país
bueno justamente queremos consideramos y
sabemos que necesitamos desesperadamente
nuevas inversiones pero que esas nuevas
inversiones que podrían dar trabajo no
vendrán si no hay seguridad jurídica es
decir si no hay un sistema judicial
independiente Por lo cual hay que
trabajar urgentemente en el
restablecimiento del sistema judicial si
no hay una administración pública que
realmente respete el estado de derecho y
eso hay que acometerlo de una manera
inmediata si no hay racionalidad fiscal
y el tema impositivo tiene que ser muy
bien
enfocado para que haya seguridad
impositiva el tema de la existencia como
decía antes de un presupuesto y
rendición de cuentas y sobre todo que
haya una seguridad jurídica en general
pero también que haya servicios en
Venezuela no hay en este momento
electricidad no hay gasolina no hay agua
potable en la mayoría de los sitios
hay internet yo misma en este momento
tengo que conectarme por el celular
porque mi internet no está funcionando
no hay educación realmente no hay salud
y todo eso hay que cometerlo de uno de
mis propuestas Es que la educación y la
salud como temas prioritarios sean
financiados Por una parte del IVA y
finalmente la igualdad y equidad de
género El Respeto del ambiente y la
inclusión Social para eliminar todas las
barreras legales y sociales y culturales
que eventualmente están impidiendo que
ciertos grupos puedan incorporarse en el
desarrollo económico y social de
Venezuela particularmente personas con
discapacidad personas con enfermedades
crónicas grupos lgbt y también adultos
mayores y otros grupos que han sido
marginados Opuestos fuera de el sistema
educativo o del sistema laboral
venezolano
volviendo a los derechos de las personas
trans porque cree que Venezuela es uno
de los países menos garantistas
creo que esto que se auto llamado
Revolución en realidad tiene una praxis
muy similar a la de las extremas
derechas y actúa y piensa así y pues por
esa razón Hoy que estamos en El Siglo 21
y estamos en el 2023 y cuando en América
Latina más del 90% de la población tiene
igualdad ante la ley y hablo de México
Costa Rica Colombia Ecuador Brasil
Uruguay Argentina chile Bolivia
parcialmente Perú parcialmente Cuba y
algunas islas del Caribe Venezuela se ha
quedado como una isla retrógrada en la
que simplemente no se decide por ejemplo
mi propia acción judicial de
reconocimiento de identidad está
pendiente ante el tribunal supremo de
Justicia desde hace 19 años y dos meses
quería terminar preguntándole cómo ve
usted este proceso electoral de 2024
cómo está siendo el camino hacia llegar
a ese proceso muy difícil
porque ayer justamente el sistema la
coalición dominante hoy en el poder
implosionó tratar de implosionar las
primarias eliminando el Consejo Nacional
electoral pidiéndole la renuncia a los
rectores chavistas y obligando a los dos
rectores que no eran chavistas también a
renunciar y nombrando una nueva perdón
una nueva comisión de nombramiento de
esos rectores ese es un proceso que
legalmente constitucionalmente se puede
llevar hasta 120 días Por ende si la
elección es para octubre y no hay
definición de la participación del
Consejo Nacional electoral en esa
elección primaria pues había que buscar
las vías para que la elección sea
autoadministrada y autogestionada por
las consecuencias que de ello derivan
desde el punto de vista financiero desde
el punto de vista técnico y desde el
punto de vista organizativo
Tamara Adrián le doy las gracias por
haber estado hoy con nosotros en directo
a América
Muchísimas gracias por esta oportunidad
Y de nuevo un gran saludo y sí si se
puede crear un mundo mejor si se puede
crear un mundo más igualitario y un
mundo más inclusivo pues esperemos que
así sea sido un placer hablar con usted
a nuestros espectadores les invito a que
sigan en France 24 porque ya volvemos
después de una breve pausa
[Música]